so this is a very interesting unboxing
i'm used to opening up and reviewing a
lot of tech but never actually hearing
the story behind it
from the people who actually made it
this is part unboxing
part interview justine what are you
unboxing
it's right behind me
what's in this box is the rmt
which stands for reality modeling tool
from asus republic of gamers now this is
an
all-new reimagined laptop collaboration
with erilson hugh co-founder of acronym
and designer david rudnick i got a
chance to chat with both of them and
after hearing the passion and
thoughtfulness that went into their
design choices with this laptop it is
definitely something that should not be
overlooked
let me have erelson and david introduce
themselves to you guys and then i'll
start opening this thing up
[Music]
for anybody who's not familiar with
acronym or like what both of you guys
kind of do and how you kind of
came about this whole project because
there's a lot of confused people
looking at the republic of gameworks uh
instagram feed right now like
who are these people what is going on my
name is aaron i'm the
principal designer and one of the
co-founders of a brand called acronym
and acronym has been around for almost
almost 20 years
i guess you call it an underground brand
it's not something everybody knows
our whole thing has been to approach
apparel not
from a purely from a fashion or
aesthetic sense but as if
they are um in a sense tools how did you
and david meet so how long have you guys
been working together
uh david and i met on twitter actually
oh my gosh that's incredible that's how
i meet all of my friends now
i got into graphic design as someone who
studying art history in college loved
music erlson literally
happened to be fans of a lot of music
that i listen to and love as well
and so he kind of got to know a bit of
of my design
and we kind of we kind of met through
that i've always
been a little bit of an outsider to the
design world i think because like coming
in i was self-taught and i had some
skepticism about
certain kinds of industrial process
errolson has been a huge inspiration to
me
and someone who i'm incredibly grateful
to have met
and to have a chance to see the way that
haroldstone works it greatly resonates
with the way that i
feel that naturally i want to approach
design as well which is to solve
problems from the ground up something
that david touched on was the unboxing
experience
of this laptop and how much thought
actually goes in to the process of
packaging
one thing we've definitely tried to do i
think hopefully this will be a fun
unboxing it's not designed to be an
extravagant unboxing
or something which is there to craft
or to affirm preconceived expectations
of what a luxury hardware experience
might be
or a conventional high-end gaming
experience might be
[Music]
okay here it is guys the unboxing
is happening right the second
boxes upon boxes
here is the power cable so it's got this
nice
bubble packaging around it to protect it
i love they have their little logo
it's also etched on the power adapter
this is nice i'm going to reuse this to
ship out
some things this is so
sharp
after talking to these guys i feel like
everything means
something even if we don't know what it
is yet
clue oh look at this
this is like a little usb stick but also
fashion make it usb but make it fashion
that's what i've been saying
forever a note
what is this what is this what is this
oh is this a is this a puzzle this seems
to be a puzzle i'm wondering
if when we put this in this will make
sense
what does it mean
we're about to find out or maybe we
won't
also has the really cool bubble
packaging feels so
protective it also feels
so comfy this feels like a camping
pillow
i'm really tired i haven't slept in like
four weeks maybe
so here's all of the packaging it's cool
because they do have their reality
modeling tool
logo right here and i was like what does
this
mean probably would have normally just
looked at this and be like that's a cool
logo
now i know what this actually means and
now you do too
the framing of the device this this
phrase that we use the reality modeling
tool
uh this strange way we call it rmt01 you
know this just basically speaks to
the fundamental philosophy behind what
we've been talking about this is this
kind of
emotional design language that we've
been trying to kind of approach the
machine with
really thinking about the view of what
it means to use a laptop
the key aspect of the relationship we
really wanted to emphasize
is as a creator as a gamer your hardware
it gives you the possibility to create
worlds of your own you will have seen
this on the promotional materials
that's what we call the rmt cascade logo
and it's the logo the reality modeling
tool
but it's very simple there are these two
planes here two kind of vertical lines
and there's this transfer between them
and you can view one of them as a laptop
screen and one of them is the viewer and
they both pass information back and
forth
and that's just like that very simple
logo the cascade
is kind of just the visual
representation of some of the philosophy
behind this project it's
this screen that kind of goes two ways
the big this case is also into you
it is
any more secrets in here i feel like
this is just a machine
full of secrets
i will leave no corner of this unturned
i don't trust you guys
okay clear this will be the first time
that i don't throw this on the ground
because i also feel like there's
probably some secrets in here too
oh there's a secret my serial number
i'll save this
i have these i gotta be careful it's a
liability
and here it is the actual laptop itself
look at this
they put like a little velcro here so
you can open it up
oh boy look at this look how cool
i love all these little perforations and
since i did kind of get a little preview
of it
i now know that part of this is made up
of led lights
and it looks really cool that came from
the asus
republican gamers design lab they came
up with this new
you know idea of having an led display
and
making the laptop part of the
environment and sort of like an output
as well as
you know input we just tried our best to
work with that and make it do
interesting things the existing version
of the g14 the anime
led matrix as it's referred to it's
integrated
into the hardware in a kind of rhombus
shape and one thing that we wanted to do
which we thought was interesting is very
in keeping with acronyms interests in
playing with ideas of opacity
transparency
of being able to hide of being able to
control when you make something visible
one of the very simple gestures that we
did is the only formal
change is that we requested that the
perforations be drilled to cover the
entire top surface when those lights
come on they
kind of emerge out of the void rather
than clearly being
in a kind of like array that's there
that can turn on or off it can be loud
but it can also be quiet
and that simple gesture adds i think a
lot to the way that the machine even can
function
kind of emotionally one of the things
that i thought was really kind of a neat
perspective they kind of hid all of the
branding
normally when you open up a laptop
you're greeted with like a logo right
here
this is very minimal they put model
information over here on the side you
don't see it but if you want to see it
you can
positioning of the device name on the
outside
edge of the closed screen part so this
here has the engraving of zephyrus g14
acronym reality modeling tool rmto1 that
allowed us to again create the blank
screen surround and to have no brain
on the inside of the object so when
you're using it it's just between you
and the tool it reminds me of the very
very for me very beautiful typographic
design gesture of the branding on camera
lenses or mac as ice
or where you see these engraved around
the operational surface
machine
[Music]
and at first glance this just seems
kind of nonsensical there's a bunch of
keys there are a bunch of different
colors but guess what there was actually
a lot of thought that went behind this
[Music]
color branding is like a huge part of so
many experiences today
to come up with a color space that
feels like it's not referencing some
obvious
like thing like for example it's all
neons or it's camouflage or it's this or
that some of the background behind the
color space of this keyboard
there's three keys which are in
different colors to the rest
of the colored keys the numbers one two
three
if you're a gamer those are kind of
action hotkeys obviously
we also wanted to kind of put them as
visual function keys in your eye line
when you're using the keyboard that are
different to pure like bloomberg
terminal like punching function keys
like on the f line or something
so that the color space around where
you're active
is kind of it's in reference to the hand
position of the user some of these are
like traditional function keys like the
shift
but some of them kind of infiltrate the
keyboard and then move on to it and this
is also again that idea of this kind of
supporting synthesis
where we didn't want it to just be like
function keys are important
letters are for typing but rather to say
something like actually
think about like the system and space of
this and the harmony between these two
experiences
this color is called shale this color is
kurumatsu which is a japanese pine and
this color is arcta
they are natural shades they are the
kind of shades you would experience if
you're out in a forest or in wood
rather than expectations of highly
artificial super brights that you might
see on the keyboard but i almost feel
there's something
kind of calming in zen that this
keyboard can kind of become almost like
a private guard
[Music]
anything else in there don't think so
so it's time to turn it on hello friend
hello friend do not concede
the future do not accept extinction
the tool is liberated
surprised me i think once we put that
usb stick in
we might have some answers so this isn't
being marketed as a gaming laptop but it
definitely
is capable of being perfect for gaming
it has an eight core 16 thread amd ryzen
9 processor an nvidia geforce rtx 2060
32 gigs of ram a one terabyte solid
state drive it has a 60 hertz 14 inch
ips level display that's pantone
validated for color accuracy it also has
adaptive sync variable refresh rate
technology for ultra smooth gaming
it's like what is the actual audience if
it's not gamer specific but yes you can
game on it who really is the audience
for this
i think we're trying to define the
current creative uh by
by looking at an activity that they do
or narrowing them down to some sort of a
template is already
impossible and sort of speaks to our
point of like we don't really know
what people are going to do with it and
i think in today's day and age where
the type of multi-faceted lives
everybody leaves we may be classified as
a graphic designer
but one day you're going to make you
know a music track the next day
all of these things are so fluid right
now it's really impossible to say the
only common denominator is that you're
creative
this is based off a previous release the
zephyrus g14 so basically
they were handed this laptop and given
the creative freedom to push the limits
of what's possible
now my first thought was how difficult
that must have been because trying to
design within the hardware constraints
that were already set up that can be
really difficult so they used a lot of
different custom materials
etching machining and specially
developed paints
and they even made an entirely new
custom typeface for the keyboard
did you create this typeface then yes so
there's two
primary typefaces on the machine first
axis tempest erelson and i built
together
it's what i call a technical sarah the
conventional aesthetic that people use
to suggest something is
highly technical is they use a kind of
sans-serif modernist font but actually
an enormous part of what acronym does
is almost an ancient art you can be
highly futuristic
with traditional craft but the serif and
the evidence of what is what remains in
a seraph
is the legacy of the hand of the brush
of the pen
of the moment where the letter was drawn
when it came to designing a typeface for
acronym i said to allison you know
everyone's going to expect us to do a
sans-serif wouldn't it be beautiful if
we could somehow try and create
a technical serif that had the level of
simplicity and
poise and quiet thought behind it that
the acronym product does
and so that's where we came to access
tempest which is this technical serif
that we use on the rmt
and then there's another secondary
typeface which is
a sans serif which is a supporting
typeface
which also shows that no system should
venerate purely
like should be purely dogmatic is to say
like beauty is the human body because
we're building a tool
beauty is the marriage of these systems
when they fit together properly
no i think this is so great because i
feel like nobody's gonna have when they
open this up like this whole thought
process that you guys have gone through
is so
intense that i feel like everybody needs
to sort of understand
look down at my computer now i'm like oh
yeah you're right it is sans-serif
that's weird but i hope that that will
even if you can't put your finger on it
like the voice of the keyboard
will be different to a keyboard that
you've experienced before
so it all started up i did some of the
updates the first thing that i wanted to
check out was the led lights
on the back of this so there's actually
this little interface that you can
customize you can add in all kinds of
designs of your own but they do have
some acronym errols and ones already on
here for you
there's also a text effect so you can
type whatever you want and it'll show up
on the front of this laptop this would
have been really amazing when i used to
work at coffee shops because
people would always come up to me and
just ask me what i'm doing like
do you not see that i have headphones on
i'm clearly
focusing on working and you want to come
up and ask me what i'm doing
no so what i would like to do is go to
the front of the laptop don't talk to me
[Music]
don't talk to me i am busy thank you
at least i said thank you so right now i
added in all of the graphics that they
have in here
and they're all running as a loop but
you can see it oh there it is there it
is there it is look at it look at it
look at it
oh wow oh yeah that's pretty cool
let's test out the brain oh look at that
i'm officially logged into the brain i
have an account i made my first
brain brain is full of thinking
and it hurts they have a demo brain for
me to look at
[Music]
it says that my brain box is empty
should i be offended
so obviously this is my first time using
the software i don't actually know how
to use it yet i'll just let erelson tell
you a little bit more about it and how
he uses it
it's actually a visual um organization
tool
sort of like mind mapping but it's
different because it's actually it's
truly non-linear you can map things out
visually and associatively
in a matrix of data points which are
called thoughts
aptly and these thoughts can be attached
to any type of
attachment or data it could be
referencing a text document or an audio
file or video file or a website
it was conceived and invented by my
brother and it's a piece of software
that i've used
for my entire professional life
basically so we spoke to harlan my
brother and we're like yo
can we do a version of the brain
specifically for this laptop
the last thing that is really really
crucial
to this video is what is on this drive
and what is this it's something that we
have to solve
and i'm afraid that i'm not going to be
able to solve it in the confines of this
video
[Music]
it it's empty
i don't believe that they just give you
a flash chart really
did i just get tricked yeah i'm not mad
about it
um okay so i thought this was going
gonna be a secret that doesn't answer
the question
of what is this i don't believe that
they wouldn't put anything on here
i think there's there's got to be
something on this
everything must be questioned
but there's nothing wait wait a minute
wait a minute oh do not open
wait a minute no hold on a second what
is
this it says do not open am i not
actually supposed to open it
what the heck is happening what is this
wait this usb key has been i can't read
it when it's closed up
i gotta back up wait a minute so there
was something on it
if you're reading this our efforts to
engineer the public
oh this usb key has been formatted to
facilitate the machine's connection
what this was their brain that they
created oh
boy so it looks like on the usb drive
is the brain but i actually went and
downloaded it before i put the drive in
so it looks like i had set up my own
brain
but this gave me access to theirs is
that going to help me solve this puzzle
i'm going to solve this but not not
right now
look this says do not open this says
delete me no i'm opening it where's all
this stuff
look there's stuff what is all this
stuff in here i must say that i'm
confused impressed excited and i
definitely need to spend some more time
with this computer but this is really
cool i mean i absolutely love
the fact that they have a very
thoughtful design everything has a
meaning i mean even just
oh these led lights are so great very
excited
to really just inspect this for some
more secrets that i might have missed
[Music]
we want you to think as a gamer and also
as a creator
what can i do with this thing how can i
command it
how can it serve me how can i use this
to construct
or model the reality i'm interested in
seeing
[Music]
my manifesto that hurt
i've hit myself